i'm so tired
i broke a nail i'm so broken stars
they're just like us
and kelly clarkson just proved it while
quarantining at home with her kids
i am full-on mom's mode taraji p henson
filled in as guest host on kelly's talk
show while the 39 year old mom of two
isolated at home with her kiddos
seven-year-old river and five-year-old
remington during the episode which was
filmed several weeks ago but only aired
this week the grammy winner virtually
called into her show rocking a bathrobe
no makeup and an eye mask reading shh
sometimes women don't rise taraji
sometimes look sometimes we fall i
thought we were done with quarantining
right and i'm so tired
i broke a nail i'm so broken this is me
broken
all my makeup's expired america this is
what i look like you're welcome kelly
didn't explain exactly why she and her
family were quarantining but she did
imply that they had some sort of
exposure to covid19 i'm not even sick
it's so weird and now we're keeping it
safe like many parents one of her main
activities in quarantine is watching and
re-watching the new disney hit and canto
delivery
i gave you the special since you're the
only madrigal kid with no gift i call it
the nut special special uh thanks when i
watch a movie with my children it's like
watching three movies okay
you watch and we're watching in kanto
i'll show you my broken nail
um and kanto and then you're listening
to my son who always leaves like mid
movie and just starts singing the
soundtrack so you have the movie going
and he's singing the soundtrack and then
you have river
who literally just right after the
lioness said she just repeats like she's
memorizing dialogue for a play
and if all that isn't relatable enough
the stronger singer points out that she
still has all of her christmas
decorations up look
it's busy okay there's a lot going on
and so i have not had time to i have all
my stuff up
oh wow that's okay that was taken today
they asked me that my they were like you
have your christmas stuff up and i was
like don't judge me judge away america
kelly wasn't kidding she's booked and
busy i like being busy e.t can now
confirm the songbird is back on the set
of her daytime talk show and likely
gearing up for another season of the
voice
i feel like i'm nailing it kelly
actually won the most recent season back
in december with her team members girl
named tom making history as the first
group to ever take home the big prize
i'm literally speechless i don't know
what to say i mean we're a trio we came
on thinking like maybe this will be a
flop you know no one will turn their
chairs for three voices you know i don't
know i just don't know
odds are against you on the show no
groups never made it this far how do you
help navigate them into their next steps
it's so important to surround yourself
with such a good team of good people
that you trust and you want to work with
and because that's it it's like you have
the talent you have the package you
write you do all these things like it's
about finding people to be on your team
that believe in you to get you there and
next up kelly set to host a new show
american song contest alongside snoop
dogg a musical competition where artists
all over the country will vie for the
title of best original hit
there's a person representing every
state every part and they all enter in
this competition and the cool thing
about it too is that it's original songs
and as a songwriter i think that's
awesome so whether she's winning the
voice quarantining at home or gearing up
for the next gig kelly is always goals
[Music]
you